in this video we're going to break down
what each Harry Potter character was
supposed to look like comparing the book
descriptions and the film appearances of
every main character first up we have
the boy who lived himself Harry Potter
in the books Harry is described as
having a thin face knobbly knees black
hair and bright green eyes he also wears
round glasses held together with a lot
of cellot tape because of his cousin
Dudley's bullying the only thing he
likes about his appearance is his
lightning shaped scar on his forehead
which marks him as the one who survived
Voldemort's attack as a baby in the
movies Daniel Radcliffe plays Harry and
he does a great job of capturing his
personality and courage however there
are some noticeable differences between
his appearance and the book description
for one thing Daniel has blue eyes not
green because he was allergic to the
contact lenses that would have changed
his eye color another detail that some
fans noticed was the placement of the
scar which was slightly off center
instead of in the middle of his forehead
this was actually JK Rowling's decision
who told the director to make it razor
sharp just off center also some fans
have said Harry scar should look like
more realistic lightning like this
rather than the cartoon tunish one we
got in the films next we have Harry's
best friend and the brightest Witch of
her age Hermione Granger in the books
Hermione is described as having bushy
brown hair large front teeth and brown
eyes she's often teased for being a
know-it-all and a teacher's pet but she
doesn't let that stop her from being
smart and ambitious in the movies Emma
Watson plays Hermione and she is perfect
for the role she portrays Hermione's
intelligence wit and compassion very
well however her appearance is also
different from the book description Emma
has Sleek wavy hair not bushy and her
teeth are normal size not larger than
average these changes were made to make
Emma look more attractive and less nerdy
but some fans felt they took away from
Hermione's character development and
uniqueness moving on we have Harry's
other best friend and the youngest son
of the Weasley family Ron Weasley in the
books Ron is described as having a long
nose freckles and bright red hair he's
tall and gangly and often wears
hand-me-down clothes from his older
brothers he's good at chess and quidd
but not very good at school work he's
also funny loyal and sometimes jealous
of Harry's Fame and Fortune and the the
movies Rupert Grint plays Ron and he's
very similar to the book description he
has the red hair the freckles and the
long nose he also wears the handm down
clothes and has the goofy Expressions he
does a great job of showing Ron's humor
friendship and insecurity the only
difference is that roer is not as tall
and skinny as Ron is supposed to be but
that's not really a big deal next up we
have the mysterious Professor Snape the
potions master and the head of the
Slytherin house in the books Snape is
described as having a thin sow face
greasy black hair and cold black eyes he
is long black robes that make him look
like a bat he's very strict sarcastic
and biased against Harry and his friends
he also has a dark past and a hidden
agenda that's revealed later in the
series in the movies Alan Rickman plays
Snape and he is amazing he captures
Snape's voice mannerisms and expressions
perfectly he also looks very similar to
the book description except for his age
Alan Rickman was much older than Snape
is supposed to be since Snape was only
in his 30s when he taught at Hogwarts
however this doesn't affect his
performance or his character Arc and he
is widely regarded as one of the best
actors in the Harry Potter movies next
we have the wise and Powerful Headmaster
of Hogwarts Albus Dumbledore in the
books Dumbledore is described as having
a long silver beard Half Moon spectacles
and twinkling blue eyes he wears
colorful robes and a pointed hat and he
carries a long thin wand he is very kind
gentle and humorous but also very clever
mysterious and manipulative he knows a
lot about magic and history and he has a
plan to defeat Voldemort in the movies
two actors played Dumbledore since the
first one Richard Harris passed away
after the second movie Richard Harris
was very close to the book description
with his long beard his glasses and his
soft voice he also showed Dumbledore's
kindness wisdom and humor very well
however some fans felt that he was too
frail and old to show Dumbledore
strength and power the second actor
Michael gamen was very different from
the book description he had a shorter
beard no glasses and darker eyes he also
wore darker robes and a more modern hat
he showed Dumbledore's Energy Authority
and Charisma very well but he also made
him more Angry impatient and emot than
he was in the books har I protest har
you put your name in the cou of the fire
some fans like this change While others
kind of hated it Voldemort is the most
powerful and Evil dark wizard of all
time he's known as the Dark Lord he who
must not be named or you know who he has
a pale snake-like face red eyes and
slits for nostrils he has no hair
eyebrows or eyelashes and he's very thin
and tall and wears long black robes he
has a high cold voice and a cruel laugh
he's obsessed with immortality power and
pure blood Supremacy Ralph Fen plays
Voldemort in the films and he's very
close to the book description he has the
pale snake-like face and the slits for
nostrils he also doesn't have hair
eyebrows or eyelashes and he's very thin
and tall and has the high cold voice and
a cruel laugh M Moody is a former Aura a
dark wizard catcher who is hired as the
defense against the dark arts teacher in
Harry's fourth year at Hogwarts he's
nicknamed Madi ey because he has a
magical eye that can see through
anything even the back of his head in
the books he has a wooden leg and a long
Twisted scar across his face he has a
Gruff voice and a paranoid personality
and is very suspicious of everyone and
everything often saying constant
vigilance Brendan gleon plays Madi moody
in the films and he's very similar to
the book description he has the magical
eye the wooden leg and the long Twisted
Scar the only difference is that his
hair is brown instead of gray in the
books Bellatrix lrange is described as
one of the most dangerous and fanatical
Death Eaters she is the cousin of Sirius
Black and the sister of Narcissa Malfoy
she has long black hair a thin pale face
and dark heavily litted eyes she has a
high girlish voice and a mad cackling
laugh she's sadistic arrogant and cruel
and enjoys inflicting pain and suffering
on others Helena bonam Carter plays
Bellatrix Le strange in the films and
she is very close to the book
description she has the long black hair
the thin pale face and the dark heavily
litted eyes she's sadistic arrogant and
cruel and she's one of the most
memorable and terrifying villains in the
entire series Neville Longbottom is a
Gryffindor student in Harry's year in
the books he's described as being clumsy
forgetful and timid and he's often
bullied by Draco Maloy and his friends
he's also pretty bad at most subjects
especially potions and charms but he's
really good at herbology Matthew Lewis
plays Neville long bottom in the films
and he's very similar to the book
description he's clumsy forgetful and
timid and also pretty bad at most
subjects but he's still good at
herbology the biggest difference is that
he undergos a dramatic physical
transformation from a chubby bucktooth
boy to a handsome muscular young man by
the final film this makes him more
attractive and popular but also less
relatable and realistic
Luna love good is a Ravenclaw student in
jinny's year in the books she is very
eccentric and quirky and she believes in
many strange things such as narles
crumple horn snorkacks and wax birs she
has long dirty blonde hair a pale face
and silvery gray eyes Ivana Lynch plays
Luna love good in the movies and she is
very close to the book description she
has the long dirty blonde hair the pale
face and the Silvery gray eyes and
matches the odd and colorful clothes and
accessories that she wore in the books
she is certainly one of the most unique
and lovable characters in the entire
series Jenny Weasley is the youngest
child and only daughter of Arthur and
Molly Weasley she is a Gryffindor
student in the year below Harry in the
book she's described as having red hair
brown eyes and a freckled nose she's
also very brave strong and independent
and doesn't let anyone push her around
she's good at quidd and she plays as a
chaser for the Gryffindor team she's
also very good at Magic and can perform
powerful spells and charms in the films
Bonnie Wright plays Jenny Weasley and
she's somewhat different from the book
description she matches her physical
appearance but her role in the films is
much smaller and less developed than in
the books and she doesn't show much of
her personality skills or relationship
with Harry she plays as a chaser on the
Gryffindor team but doesn't have many
scenes or lines she also becomes Harry's
girlfriend in his sixth year and his
wife in the epilogue but the romance
isn't very convincing or romantic like
it is in the books Sirius Black is
Harry's Godfather and in the books
Sirius is described as having long black
matted hair and a gaunt face with sunken
eyes and a pointed nose he also has a
long beard and a tattoo on his chest he
looks much older than his actual age due
to his time in asab band in the films
serus is played by Gary Oldman who has
short curly black hair and a stubble he
doesn't have a tattoo or a beard and he
looks more handsome and less Haggard
than his book counterpart he also wears
more stylish clothes such as leather
jackets and scarves Lily and James are
Harry Potter's parents and in the books
they're both very young when they die at
only 21 years old they have bright green
eyes and jet black hair respectively
which Harry inherits from them Lily's
hair is long and thick while james' hair
is messy and sticks up at the back James
also wears round glasses and has a thin
face like Harry in the films Lily and
James are played by older actors who
look more like Harry's grandparents than
his parents their eyes aren't green and
their hair isn't as Vivid as it is in
the books Lily's hair is shorter and
straighter while James's hair is neater
and darker James also has a rounder face
and thicker glasses do you prefer how
these characters looked in the films or
do you wish you could see them how they
were described in the books let me know
in the comments below and don't forget
to like And subscribe for more videos
like this thanks for
watching